[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre la disputa entre
venezuela y guyana por la región del
esequibo una zona rica en yacimientos de
petróleo oro diamante uranio y una
amplia diversidad que cada país reclama
como suya desde hace casi 200 años nos
acompaña el señor asdrúbal aguiar
profesor de derecho internacional
abogado ex juez de la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos
además ex ministro de la secretaría de
la presidencia y relaciones exteriores
interiores de venezuela gracias por
acompañarnos doctor a guiar y estar aquí
con nosotros en france 24 este viernes
en la corte internacional de justicia en
la ya se discute sobre esta controversia
territorial le pregunto cuáles son
resumidamente los argumentos de
venezuela y de guyana para reclamar esta
región
pero en primer lugar en el caso de
venezuela cuando fue reconocida su
independencia gran bretaña aceptó que
los límites de venezolanos estaban
situados justamente a partir del río
esequibo hacia la zona occidental que
cubren los 150.000 kilómetros de lo que
se conoce como la guayana esequiba y
luego a finales del siglo 19
inglaterra a través de unos mapas
fraudulentos trata de mover su presencia
hasta las bocas del orinoco
considerando que ellas eran estratégicas
para el dominio de suramérica y se monta
un laudo arbitral entre eeuu rusia y
gran bretaña en el que no participa
venezuela ni fuese venezolano ni
abogados venezolanos y como consecuencia
de ese laudo se le confiscó y se le
quitaron esos 150 mil kilómetros
cuadrados acto seguido en 1966 en
vísperas justamente de la independencia
de la orgullosa república cooperativa de
guyana inglaterra acepta efectivamente
que hay que buscar una solución
y satisfactoria práctica para resolver
esa controversia histórica que se tenía
justamente entre el reino unido- este y
venezuela guyana sostienen por su parte
que lo que debe debatirse exclusivamente
la validez o no del laudo arbitral de
1899 ahora abogado cuál es el papel de
la corte internacional de justicia y
cuál es la postura de guyana y venezuela
frente a esta intervención de la corte
mire el secretario general de naciones
unidas de conformidad con el acuerdo y
negra que se firmó en 1966 decidió
referir la controversia a la corte
internacional de justicia hubo un gran
debate inicial dentro de la corte por
dos razones centrales venezuela no se
presentó este a la corte en el momento
en que se hacía el debate preliminar
arguyendo que ella no había no había
dado su consentimiento para que la
jurisdicción obligatoria de la corte
pudiese imponerse en estas
circunstancias y en segundo lugar se
argumentaba y sigue argumentando que el
convenio de ginebra expresa claramente
qué
solución tiene que ser una solución
amistosa práctica recíprocamente
satisfactoria entre las partes con lo
cual el tema del derecho quedaría total
y absolutamente excluido esta es la
situación que se debatió lamentablemente
la corte decidió por mayoría sobre la
base de la protesta de seis de los
jueces este que ella entraría a conocer
en primer lugar de la nulidad del laudo
arbitral y en el supuesto de que lo
declarase nulo procedería de manera
inmediata a delimitar la frontera
terrestre entre guyana y venezuela ahora
cómo está la situación hoy en esta
región guyana ya ha anunciado que en la
zona hay mayor presencia militar
venezolana no hay presencia militar
venezolana por razones obvias recuérdese
que venezuela tiene toda una franja
marítima que está en las zonas del delta
del orinoco en donde se están
produciendo situaciones realmente
difíciles con las migraciones de
venezolanos sobre todo hacia la zona de
trinidad
en el caso específico de la zona en
reclamación
hay que señalar lo siguiente que hoy en
día lo que hay un gran debate entre las
petroleras internacionales que han
logrado este ocupar por vía de concesión
en el bloque starbucks en el cual tratan
de extender la exploración y explotación
de petróleo hasta lo que son las costas
indiscutidas de venezuela inclusive del
punto de vista marítimo cerrando la
posibilidad de que venezuela salga al
océano atlántico al punto tal de que la
exxon está financiando los honorarios de
los abogados de guyana lo han confesado
públicamente el gobierno y la propia
exxon les han hecho entrega de 15
millones de dólares para que sostengan
este litigio ante la corte internacional
de justicia abogado gracias por su
tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 que tenga usted un feliz resto
de día de ustedes también continua con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias
[Música]